[Music]
dozens of civil rights organizations are
expressing their concerns over the
possibility
of a new domestic terrorism bill that
would ostensibly
focus on white nationalists and
neo-nazis the issue is what groups are
considered terrorists and whether that
constitutes
profiling here's correspondent mark
meredith
in his inaugural address president biden
vowed to combat hate groups which he
sees
as a growing national security threat
now
a rise of political extremism white
supremacy
domestic terrorism that we must confront
and we will defeat this week democratic
illinois congressman brad schneider
introduced the domestic terrorism
prevention act which establishes
domestic terrorism offices at the
justice department
homeland security and fbi would require
congress be briefed twice a year on
domestic terrorist activity
and examine if hate groups have
infiltrated military and
law enforcement agencies
senate majority whip dick durbin says
following the recent capitol hill riots
lawmakers should feel an urgent need to
act the house passed this legislation
last fall
when i tried to have a call to the
senate unfortunately the senate
republicans objected
i hope they have a change of heart now
critics fear the legislation
may create more controversy and unfairly
label some americans as domestic
terrorists
we need to tread very carefully and
again we have laws on the books
the vast majority of americans do not
support
these groups no matter what side of the
political spectrum they're on
this week 135 civil rights groups sent
congress a letter
urging lawmakers to focus on hate groups
but not to enact a new domestic
terrorism charge
becky munroe is with the leadership
conference on civil and human rights
when we've had new criminal charges
created however well-intentioned
they have ended up coming back to harm
the very same communities in this case
that white nationalists are seeking to
harm
their privacy concerns too with some
lawmakers worried the government already
has too much power
to surveil its citizens starting today
the white house is directing the
national security council to better
focus on the threat violent extremists
pose
the administration also wants a full
review of how officials can disrupt
extremist networks
brett mark thank you let's pray